okay so the other way of doing this so
so one way one of the things to say what
you just said which is
use these powers for good the other
thing i've i've been able to do
is is the opposite which is when i see
somebody do something for evil but it
works i try to learn from it
and so for example remember the first
time i saw that i'll give you a recent
example first no i completely agree so
trump is uh somebody who i'm not a fan
of i think the guy is bad in all these
different ways
um but when i watch him the guy is an
incredibly effective
communicator and he's not polished
he doesn't use fancy 15 words he um
doesn't have a lot of substance behind
what he's saying but the guy
is like a a master
of of communication the guy knows how to
get his point across
uh in a way that resonates with people i
completely agree scott adams who's the
creator of gilbert was talking about
this when trump was running if you
haven't seen it go read
scott adams's blog um he's the creator
of dilbert and he was early on when
trump first announced his candidacy
scott adams called it he goes this guy's
going to win and people were like what
he goes i've been studying persuasion
for 20 years
i've been studying hypnosis i've been a
communicator through cartoon
i know an effective communicator when i
see one this guy is a master he goes
and so he would come up with whenever
trump would say things like
um low energy jeb or whatever when he
would like call jeb bush low energy
um he was like these are linguistic kill
shots
these are and or when he would talk
about the wall he'd be like it's a great
big wall a huge wall
and he's like he's painting a picture in
people's minds which is much better
than talking about policy and uh so so
you can learn from people that you think
are using it for now well he
he and he called out that he was gonna
win he called it he was gonna win
months before anybody even took him
seriously when 538 was like this guy's
got a zero percent chance
scott adams was like this guy's gonna
win and uh of course
if he was wrong nobody would even really
pay attention to it because you know but
when you're right
on a country and prediction you get all
the credit and
the other example of this was hitler so
hitler when hitler was rising to power i
studied how did this guy get so popular
what did this guy do because when you
watch him speak he's not a very
compelling guy
um but they did a lot of things so one
thing i remember
that stood out to me this i was in
seventh grade and i remember learning
about this
and when hitler was trying to rise to
power all the political
campaign posters were all like full
color
lots of text uh people trying to explain
their position on things
and hitler went the other way everything
he did was black and white which would
be
normally it would not stand out but he
was like well i will contrast
everybody else who's using tons of color
on their stuff i'll go black and white
the second thing was he would use only
like big images and like really powerful
images and not a bunch of text
and then he would use movies as
propaganda and you know fill the cinema
with people
to watch a movie but it was very much a
propaganda thing behind it so
even though he used it for evil those
techniques and principles
are interesting to learn from for me as
somebody who wants to
you know have a strong toolkit that i
can use for good
i completely agree i was reading i've
been going on so many wikipedia
holes now that i'm home so much i was
reading
about uh i read look at hitler's
wikipedia because
i was reading about world war ii and it
let me like i was reading about the
mafia then world war ii and then
like and it was like he's like his rise
to power
was because he uh like would speak at
these
uh i don't know what what the equivalent
of is now but
just like halls where he like bars like
veteran halls
and i'm like wait a minute he started as
a speaker
that's it right it was kind of crazy